[Music]
Mass Effect Andromeda is a little more
than a month away and when you finally
get to play it you won't be wasting your
time on tedious and insignificant chores
Bioware has said that the game will have
meaningful side quests I'm Matt this is
a game spot news update and make sure to
LIKE and subscribe for more coverage of
Bioware's upcoming space game producer
febreze condom eanes told pc gamer we
are approaching the completionist aspect
very differently because we've done and
learned a lot from Dragon Age
Inquisition but we've also observed what
other games have been doing like The
Witcher and it was very important for us
that the quantity of scope doesn't
downgrade the quality of whatever you
are doing there Mass Effect Andromeda
releases on March 21st and as for the
side activities will see barware has
confirmed enemy bases giant bosses and
the return of loyalty missions will keep
you up to date as more about the space
RPG is revealed but for now you can
check out our breakdown video of the
second cinematic trailer